Maybe we don't want all of
the listings to appear right away.
We want to let the user chose to show or
hide them all on the click of a button.
First we'll add two buttons,
show listings and
hide listing and a little bit
more HTML to structure our page.
I also added some CSS
to go with the HTML.
Each button has a unique ID,
show-listings and hide-listings.
Let's keep the naming simple here.
We'll create an event listener for
each button to make some functions
happen when the buttons are clicked.
Here are our event listeners.
Clicking the show listings button
calls the showListings function, and
clicking the hide listings button
calls the hideListings function.
Now, in the initialized function, we're
going to keep almost everything else
the same, in that we'll still create
an array of markers on initialize.
However we're not going to set the map
parameter on those markers right away.
We also won't extend the bounds
of the map just yet.
Instead we'll move that stuff
into our showListings function.
So the showListings function will
loop through our markers array,
set the map to map on
each of the markers and
extend the bounds of the map
to fit each of the markers.
Conversely, we'll create
the hideListings function which
loops through our markers array again
and sets the map to null on each marker.
This doesn't delete the markers,
it just hides them.
Awesome!
Now we have some points on the map,
some interactions with the user, and
lots of room for creativity.